Another really important source of visual
information are movie files. The tool box
that you have been using ships with a large
number of images and also smaller number of
movies.
So let’s scroll through the provided images,
and some of them are familiar ones that you
have either seen already or will see later
during this course, and right down the bottom
here there is a movie file, we know it is
a movie file because it has got an extension
of .MPG, short for MPEG. And we will talk
a little bit about that shortly.
Let me double click on this movie file and
it comes up in a movie player. It is not a
brilliantly exciting movie; it is a view from
a window looking down on an urban intersection,
with cars and trucks. It is in black and white,
and it runs for only a very short amount of
time.
So what we are going to do now is to read
some frames from that movie sequence into
the MATLAB workspace. I am going to do that
by creating a movie camera object. This is
related to the camera object we looked at
before, but this particular movie object is
of the class movie.
We are going to give it the name of the file
that contains the movie, traffic_sequence.mpg.
Open that up and it creates a new movie object
in our workspace. Now we can grab frames from
this movie, by using the grab method, just
as we have done for the other camera objects
we have seen before. What that does is grab
the first frame from the movie and display
it in a window. I can get the next frame.
And the next frame, the next frame, and so on.
If we display the movie object just by typing
in the name and return, it gives us some information
about the movie. It tells us the size of the
individual frames, that they are 720 columns
wide, 576 rows high. The movie is recorded
at 30 frames per second and there’s a total
of 351 frames in this movie, for a run time
of 11.7 seconds.
Movie file formats have got a lot in common
with the image file formats that we looked
at a little while ago. They comprise a container
which holds a number of objects, the first
object is the header which says something
about the size of each frame within the movie
and the format in which the audio and video
is encoded.
Often times we refer to what is called a video
codec and that is short hand for the compression
algorithm that is applied to the image frames
within the movie. And there is also an audio
codec, which is the algorithm which compresses
the audio information.
There is also some metadata associated with
the movie. It might have the type of camera,
the camera settings and again the location
at which the movie was taken. The bulk of
the file though is occupied with the frames
of the movie, which are compressed using a
video codec, and the audio data which is compressed
using the audio codec. So we need to specify
the format of the container as well as the
format of the movie data and the audio data.
So when we refer to something like an mpeg4
movie, to be more precise, what we are talking
about is an mpeg4, part fourteen container.
That means it is defined by a standard, part
of the mpeg4 standard, part fourteen of that
standard. And the video is compressed using
the H.264 standard, and the audio is compressed
using the AAC standard. So mpeg4 is a short
hand for a lot more detail about the container,
the video and the audio.
And just as with image file formats, there’s
a bunch of movie formats that are commonly
used today and some of them are container
formats, some of them are codec formats and
some of them specify the container and the
codec.